TODAY HAVE EVIDENCE TODAY IS HOW
DRAFTING PROCESS THAT WILL START
IN THE MORNING, THEY WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO SEE IT.
>> Tucker: WE CAN MAKE UP OUR
OWN MINDS, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST, AND CLOSE OBSERVER OF
ALL THINGS RUSSIA PLAZA RELATED.
SO IN MY HAND I HAVE A
DOCUMENTED THAT WILL END MSNBC'S
PRIMETIME SCHEDULE WHICH HAS
BEEN PREDICATED ON THE IDEA THAT
TRUMP IS COLLUDING WITH THE
RUSSIANS COME I ALMOST DON'T
WANT TO TELL THEM BECAUSE I DO
NOT WANT TO WRECK THEIR RATINGS
RUN, WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO
WHEN THEY FIND OUT?
WHAT IS THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
MEDIA GOING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
>> I THINK THAT THEY WILL CARRY
ON AS USUAL, TUCKER.
FOR THE VERY GOOD REASON, BUT
THEY HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH PUTIN
ON THIS.
HIS OBJECT WHICH IS A REASONABLE
ONE FOR ANY HOSTILE POWER TO
TAKE TO THE NATIONS IS THAT HE
WANTED TO SO CONFUSION.
AND HE DID SO FOR THE LAST 18
MONTHS, THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA HAVE RUN AROUND LIKE
HEADLESS CHICKENS SHRIEKING
ABOUT SOME GUY WHO HAPPENS TO BE
RELATED TO A CABINET SECRETARY
AND FINDING HIMSELF IN A BAR IN
THE STATE AND A RUSSIAN WALKS
INTO THE BAR.
AND IT IS NOT ILLEGAL TO TALK TO
RUSSIANS IN BARS OR RUSSIANS IN
DINERS OR RUSSIANS IN DEPARTMENT
STORES.
THAT IS NOT A CRIME.
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO THE BAR AND
TALK TO A RUSSIAN, GOOD LUCK TO
YOU.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IS THE GREAT
SLOW PROCESS OF AMERICAN
INVESTIGATIONS OF THIS NATURE
WHICH IS ALWAYS LOOKING IN THE
REARVIEW MIRROR.
SO THE INVESTIGATION OF STUFF
THAT HAPPENS THROUGH COMPANY,
THREE YEARS AGO, MEANWHILE,
PUTIN IS GETTING THROUGH THE
NEXT ELECTION BECAUSE EVERYBODY
ELSE IS LOOKING AHEAD WHILE WE
ARE DOING ALL OF THIS REARVIEW
MIRROR STUFF.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A GREAT
QUESTION.
BUT THE NEXT QUESTION WOULD BE,
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BASED
ON THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
WERE IN SOME WAY COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIA?
NEVER WORK AGAIN WHO HAD TO SELL
THEIR HOUSES, AND IN CLINTON'S
CASE WERE INVITED TO INDICTED,
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM?
>> I THINK THAT THAT IS A MORE
SERIOUS PROBLEM, BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THERE WERE SERIOUS QUESTION
THAT THERE WERE SERIOUS QUESTIOS
ABOUT CORRUPTION AND EXCESSIVE
USE OF MUSCLE AT THE FEDERAL
PROSECUTORIAL LEVEL.